>> Brian: WELCOME BACK.
THIS IS NATIONAL POLICE WEEK.
IT COMES AS POLICING IS NOW A
HOT TOPIC IN WASHINGTON OR MAYBE
ON YOUR KITCHEN TABLE WITH
PARTIES ON BOTH SIDES PUSHING
FOR REFORM BUT IS ANYONE ASKING
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHAT WOULD MAKE
THEIR JOBS MORE EFFECTIVE,
MAKING BEING MAKE IT EASIER OR
BETTER.
IN WASHINGTON.
IS WITH THE EXCLUSIVE LOOK AT
THE METHOD OR MYTH 2021 FROM THE
LEBANESE OF THE ACTUAL OFFICERS,
YOU KNOW THE FIRST RESPONDERS
THAT YOU SEE.
THE BAD GUYS THEY GET STABBED
SOMETIMES, THEY GET SHOT
SOMETIMES AND EVEN DELIVER
BREAKING NEWS BEFORE AN
AMBULANCE ARRIVES LIKE THESE
OFFICERS DID IN NASSAU COUNTY,
NEW YORK A FEW DAYS AGO.
HERE WAS THEIR PERSPECTIVE.
>> EVERY TIME I PULL SOMEONE
OVER YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
WALKING UP AGAINST.
[SIREN]
>> MAY I SEE YOU'RE LICENSE,
REGISTRATION AND INSURANCE,
PLEASE?
>> I CANNOT SEE WHO I'M PULLING
OVER UNTIL I ACTUALLY WALK UP TO
THE SIDE OF THEIR WINDOW.
>> THEY COULD BE WANTED FOR
MURDER.
THEY COULD HAVE GUNS IN THE CAR.
[SIREN]
>> THESE ROAD CONDITIONS WITH
THE RAIN WE LIKE TO SEE YOU GO A
LITTLE SLOWER.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> NO PROBLEM, OFFICER.
>> HAVE A GOOD DAY.
>> HE WAS COOPERATIVE.
HE WAS DAL, HE UNDERSTOOD
EVERYTHING I WAS SAYING.
GAVE A HIM A WARNING.
>> Brian: THAT GOES A LONG WAY.
>> 32 YEARS -- COMMISSION POLICE
OFFICERS MOST DANGEROUS THING
THEY DO IS A CAR STOP.
>> THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
ROUTINE CAR STOP YOU HEARD IT
AROUND THE COUNTRY UNARMED CAR
STOPS CONDUCTED WITH SOCIAL
WORKERS.
>> WITH SOCIAL WORKERS.
THIS IS THE MOST DANGEROUS JOB
WHETHER IT'S THE TRAFFIC DRIVING
BY YOU OR THE INDIVIDUAL INSIDE
THAT CAR THE PERSON YOU ARE
GOING TO ENCOUNTER ON THE STREET
THIS.  CALL WE ARE GOING TO
HANDLE NOW SIMULATED BY TWO
OFFICERS STANDING BEHIND DOORS
OF A POLICE CAR.
THE CALL COMES OUT FOR
SUSPICIOUS MALE.
ATTEMPT TO BE BURGLARIZED IN A
HOUSE AND HE MAY HAVE A WEAPON
ON HIM.
>> LEAVE ME ALONE, SIR.
>> LEAVE ME ALONE.
>> SIR, GET ON THE GROUND.
WHEN YOU SAW THE GUNS, THE
TRAINING SAYS FIRE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Brian: SOMETIMES THEY COULD
HAVE SOMETHING ELSE IN THEIR
HAND.
>> THEY ARE TRAINED TO LOOK FOR
A WEAPON.
>> WHETHER IT'S A FAKE WEAPON OR
A REAL WEAPON THERE IS A GOOD
CHANCE YOU ARE GOING TO GET
SHOT.
>> WE TRAIN TO STOP THREATS.
WE DON'T SHOOT TO KILL.
I HAVE HEARD TOO MANY TIMES ON
TV IN THIS SCENARIO THE OFFICERS
HANDLED IT PERFECTLY.
>> Brian: THIS IS THE STORY OF
2:00 IN THE AFTERNOON.
CAN YOU GIVE ME THE SAME
SCENARIO AT 2:00 IN THE MORNING.
>> YOU CAN DO THAT IN THE
LIGHT,.
>> POLICE, STOP.
SIR, NASSAU COUNTY POLICE STOP,
GET ON THE GROUND.
>> Brian: SO MUCH TOUGHER AT
NIGHT.
>> THE ENVIRONMENT CHANGES.
WHEN THE ENVIRONMENT CHANGES,
IT'S DARK, YOU DON'T GET TO SEE
THAT WEAPON JUST AS FAST.
IN THIS SCENARIO THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE, THE INDIVIDUAL HAS
GOT A KNIFE.
WE HAVE DISTANCE, WE HAVE TIME,
WE HAVE CONTROL THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO PULL THE TASER OUT.
MANY TIMES THE TASERS DON'T
WORK.
IF BOTH PRONGS DON'T HIT DOES
NOT RUN THE CURRENT THROUGH THEM
TO STUN THE PERSON.
>> SIR, YOU HAVE BEEN ASKED
SEVERAL TIMES TO DROP THE KNIFE.
DROP THE KNIFE.
>> NO,.
>> TASER, TASER, TASER.
[MOANING]
>> WHAT YOU SEE GET BACK UP.
THE TASER PRESS IT AGAIN AND
SEND MORE CURRENT BACK INTO IT.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL NOW.
>> I FEEL GREAT NOW.
I COULD HAVE RUN -- I LOST
COMPLETE CONTROL OF MY LEFT LEG.
[MOANING]
>> SO OFTEN YOU HEAR ABOUT WE
DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
MILITARY EQUIPMENT AND SURPLUS
EQUIPMENT ON THE STREET IT GIVES
THE WRONG MESSAGE TO THE
COMMUNITY.
I LOOK AT THIS VEHICLE AND
ALTHOUGH IT'S BUILT FOR A
DIFFERENT CAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE UNDER
SCRUTINY FROM WASHINGTON WHEN
THEY TALK ABOUT POLICE REFORM.
[SIREN]
>> THIS IS A, WHAT WE CALL A FAT
CAT.
WE PURCHASED IT.
THIS IS LIKE A BULLET PROOF
AMBULANCE.
IT CAN BRING MY MEN AND WOMEN
SAFELY INTO AN ENVIRONMENT OF AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER AND TAKE THOSE
VICTIMS OUT FROM THAT SAME
ENVIRONMENT.
>> Brian: YOU JUST HAD SOMETHING
WHERE YOU NEEDED THIS VEHICLE AT
THE STOP AND SHOP THAT MADE
NATIONAL NEWS.
YOU WERE ABLE TO BRING A SUSPECT
IN ALIVE.
>> THAT VEHICLE WAS ON THE SCENE
IN FRONT.
IF THE INDIVIDUALS STARTED TO
SHOOT FROM THE WINDOW AND HIT
SOMEBODY, THIS VEHICLE IS GOING
TO GET THEM OUT SAFELY.
IT'S NOT USED OFTEN, BUT WHEN IT
IS NEEDED, IT'S THERE FOR US.
>> Brian: AS WE SEE THE CELL
PHONE VIDEO AND SEE THE BODY
CAMERA VIDEO, WHAT IS IT LIKE,
GUYS, ON THE STREET LIKE THAT AS
WE SEE SCENARIOS WHERE YOU ARE
WRESTLING AROUND NONCOMPLIANT
SUSPECT.
>> CHALLENGING TIME IN POLICING
RIGHT NOW.
YOU WANT TO DO YOUR JOB OUT
THERE AND GET THE BAD GUY OFF
THE STREET AT THE SAME TIME AS
YOU SAID EVERYONE IS VIDEOTAPING
IT AND MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACKING IT IS DETERRING
US FROM DEPLOYING THE DIFFERENT
MOVES AND TECH UNIQUES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN TAUGHT.
>> QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
DISAPPEARED TOMORROW YOU HAVE TO
WONDER WILL YOU HAVE A HOME TO
GO TO AT THE END OF THE WEEK OR
LOSING OUR HOMES AND LOSING
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE.
>> IT'S A CHALLENGING TIME.
IT REALLY IS BECAUSE WE ALL TOOK
THE JOB TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND THAT'S TO HELP THE COMMUNITY
AND NOW ONCE EVERYONE IS
WATCHING IT ON THE NEWS, IT'S
SECOND GUESSING EVERY DECISION
MADE.
>> Brian: SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
NASSAU COUNTY POLICE THEIR
VERSION OF SWAT HELPING US OUT
AND UNDERSTANDING HOW HARD THEY
TRAIN TO MAKE SURE EVERYTHING
COMES OUT RIGHT.
SOMETIMES YOU DO EVERYTHING
RIGHT AND IT COMES OUT WRONG AND
WE SEE A LOT OF THAT JOINING US
NOW A MAN WHO KNOWS ALL OF THIS.
HE HAS BEEN STUDYING THIS HOT
AND HEAVY FOR OVER A YEAR.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR FROM SOUTH
CAROLINA TIM SCOTT.
SENATOR, WE WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE
A PERSPECTIVE FROM THE POLICE
OFFICER.
WE KNOW YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
POLICE REFORM.
WHAT SHOULD THEY KNOW ABOUT WHAT
YOU ARE WORKING ON?
>> WELL, BRIAN, FIRST THING WE
SHOULD SAY IS THANK GOD FOR
PEOPLE WHO PUT ON THE UNIFORM.
THIS IS NATIONAL POLICE WEEK.
SO THERE IS NO PERT TIME FOR US
TO SAY THANK YOU TO AN OFFICER
SO WHEN YOU SEE AN OFFICER
AROUND YOUR NEIGHBORHOODS,
AROUND THE STREETS, PLEASE STOP
AND SAY THANK YOU TO THOSE
OFFICERS.
TWO OF MY BROTHERS FROM ANOTHER
MOTHER, MY MENTORS KIDS BOTH ARE
DEPUTIES AND SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO DO THAT.
WHAT THEY SHOULD KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN CONGRESS IS TAKING
FIRST INTO CONSIDERATION THE
IMPORTANT WORK THAT THEY DO AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE KEEP OUR
OFFICERS SAFE.
IF YOU WANT COMMUNITIES TO BE
SAFE, YOU HAVE TO HAVE OFFICERS
WHO ARE NOT THINKING ABOUT THEIR
PERSONAL LIABILITY OR THEIR
ASSETS AS THEY RUN INTO HARM'S
WAY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
FOR QUALIFIED IMMUNITY I HAVE
BEEN FOR THE LAST YEAR OPEN FOR
PUTTING MORE OF THE ONUS ON THE
MUNICIPALITIES, ON THE COUNTIES,
ON THE STATE AND TAKING IT OFF
OF THE OFFICERS.
THAT, TO ME, IS THE WAY THAT WE
CONTINUE TO TELL THE OFFICERS
THAT WE NEED THEM GOING INTO
HARM'S WAY WITHOUT HAVING TO
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF
EXPOSURE FROM A LIABILITY
PERSPECTIVE.
>> Brian: ACADEMIES OUT.
PEOPLE RETIRING.
MASSIVE EXODUS IN JUNE TRY TO
LEAVE WITH THE MOST OVERTIME TO
RETIRE WITH THE MOST MONEY.
ON MAY 25TH.
DEMOCRATS SAID THEY WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
TALKED TO ME, ABOUT QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY, YOU TALK ABOUT SUING
THE PRECINCT NOT THE PERSON.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE NO KNOCK
WARRANTS AND TALK ABOUT THE NO
CHOKEHOLDS.
WHAT ELSE SHOULD THE POLICE
OFFICERS AND CITIZENS KNOW THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT WITH DEMOCRATS?
>> YOU MENTIONED TWO OTHER
ISSUES, NUMBER ONE, ONE THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IS SECTION 242
WHICH IS MAKING IT EASIER,
LOOKING TO LOWER THAT THRESHOLD.
I HAVE SAID THAT AS A NO GO FOR
ME, SECTION 242 IS A CRIMINAL
ELEMENT.
IN POLICE REFORM.
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN THAT
WHATSOEVER.
THE OTHER ONE IS WHAT YOU
MENTIONED HAVING THE RIGHT
EQUIPMENT, SECTION 1033 IS THE
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT CAN GO
TO POLICE OFFICES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
HAVING RUN A COUNTY WITH A
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT MYSELF
PREVIOUSLY, IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE TOOLS NECESSARY.
THERE IS A LIST THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN BANNED AND REESTABLISHING
THAT SAME LIST SILENCED ME.
BUT HAVING THAT M RAP OR THOSE
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT OR VEHICLES
THAT BRING OFFICERS SAFELY IN
HARM'S WAY TO GET THEM AND OTHER
INNOCENT FOLKS OUT OF HARM'S WAY
IS SOMETHING THAT I COMPLETELY
SUPPORT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT.
SO THOSE ARE REALLY THE TOP FIVE
ISSUES YOU JUST NAMED THEM THAT
WERE WORKING ON.
DETAIL.
WE NEED TO READ EVERY LINE,
EVERY LETTER, EVERY WORD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS NOT SOMETHING
SNEAKINGS IN THE BACK DOOR.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE NO DEAL THAN
A BAD DEAL.
>> Brian: TWO THINGS, TRAINING,
SMALLER STATIONS, SMALL
PRECINCTS DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
AND THEY HAVE TO PAY YOU MORE.
MORE MONEY HELP WITH BOTH THOSE
THINGS.
NUMBER TWO WHEN PEOPLE SAY
DEFUND THE POLICE SQUAD MEMBERS
KEEP SAYING THIS REIMAGINE
GETTING RID OF IRRECONCILABLE,
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO ABOUT
THAT SENTIMENT SENATOR?
CAN YOU DEAL WITH THAT.
>> THE WAY I WITH DEFUND THE
POLICE DUMBEST THING I HAVE
HEARD MY WHOLE LIFE HAVING
GROWING UP IN A SINGLE PARENT
HOUSEHOLD AND POVERTY WE ALWAYS
WANT POLICE OFFICERS AROUND WHEN
NECESSARY.
>> ESPECIALLY TO KEEP OUR MOMS
SAFE.